is this it looks like a highlighter no
it's some kind of spray this is my
fooders murse I've got a hospital bill
but I need to pay still an umbrella case
don't know where the umbrella is Kleenex
a beer koozie the tooth washing tooth
brushing thing whoa something for my car
that I probably shouldn't Marilyn hold
it up plain white printer paper hand
sanitizer a book about UFO abductees
this is a Father's Day card I should
have sent my dad my 4/20 recommendation
you should probably blow out this info
and prophylactics 5-hour energy also
just in case allergy stuff a picture of
two grooms on top of a wedding cake I
had a cold earlier this week an old
check stub from my last job napkins they
need
gosh I've wanted to get the battery
replaced hidden for over two years
this is a map of Dinosaur World ticket
vouchers from Costco that I haven't used
yet I have my socks on I was wearing
yesterday I have my shirt that I wore on
Monday I do this is for a GoPro a bunch
of change in paperclips a battery and a
quarter cruise just a ton of paper stuff
it here at the bottom for pens and a
grocery store receipt pair spandex